you guys ready to go yeah I'm ready
where's Nick I don't know I just saw
Nick a second ago yeah sorry guys I just
have to get something to eat
[Music]
[Music]
yeah well harden it looks hey hey what's
up guys look at lunch I know I'm good
alright should at least take that hat
off sure it's a little silly yeah I mean
it's it's become a problem it's becoming
a problem sorry guys
how's that OCA Thea's treatment I'm
enjoying it
I'm not sure how you guys what your
experiences have been like so far but uh
please share I'd love to know based on
what I've heard it seems like you're the
most positive I think I'm somewhere in
the middle and while you're having fun
with it there are issues that have yea
arisen for me it's the lack of depth I
think to the game that's making it
really hard to like stay interested in
playing over and over again especially
as a solo player because what makes up
for that depth when playing with you
guys is the fact that I can throw up on
you we can coordinate and manage ship
you know together like yeah that amount
of cooperation like that is the
experience I'm looking for and that's um
what I'm getting
[Music]
when I play by myself that doesn't work
so it's it's kind of giving me this
problem where like I always need to wait
for you guys or go online and find
people who are interested in playing
along as well
yeah but then there's that risk you run
into when you're playing with people
online like you don't know who you're
gonna get unfortunately yeah and
sometimes that's us too sometimes we're
the jerks right I feel like most of the
time we are this lot of people and
Briggs if I just find that like the
toughest thing is that when I don't have
other players like if you guys are
unavailable and I have to jump into a
ship it takes me like two or three
chances in galleons to find a crew that
has mics that is willing to communicate
that is willing to work together that
doesn't need to be taught how to play
the game and things like that obviously
that will change after release and
whatnot but I do find myself playing a
lot of solo I have been enjoying it but
I know there are some things that can
happen that can really be game breaking
I know you had it the very first time
you tried to sail alone yeah first time
I tried to sail alone on my ship and I
was like cool I'm gonna sit out and be
my own man my own pirate whatever it
didn't take long for someone to appear
on my ship kill me when I didn't expect
it fine that's the game ran i respawned
the guy was still there killing me I
expressed to you how frustrating that
was and you said look to scuttle your
ship so I had to go into a menu and tell
my ship to sink and I did that like from
the afterlife like before I got respawn
back into the world when I thought it
was safe I went back the ship was under
water but I was standing on it and so
was the guy who killed me we were both
still running around on board a ship
despite it being beneath the ocean right
and and that was that was frustrating
you know I don't want it like to quickly
say that this game is just filled with
people's and they're gonna ruin it for
everybody because I feel like a part of
this is everyone still getting used to
being on a pirate ship having cannons at
the ready right like and sometimes this
game can be pretty barren so when you
see someone else what's the easiest way
to engage it fight up
the first bait I played everyone was
like they were out for blood but then
finally further along we got is when we
kind of started to have these weird
interactions so I assume the people who
were playing the bait or people who had
already played previous ones and they
were getting used to it and they were
kind of experimenting more with how to
interact with other players rather than
just sink their ship yeah so I have
hopes that it will continue down that
path now the game is out and new players
will find ways to just cooperate but I'm
also not sure what benefit I will get in
the long run from doing that there's
only so much you can do with other
people right I mean the ultimate goal is
to succeed in these voyages get treasure
convert that into gold and then what and
then basically you buy things and make
you look better and make your ship look
better but they don't make you a more
effective pirate or a more effective
ally or enemy it's like you're
everyone's still in the base level which
I understand keeps the game balanced but
it also makes it difficult for me to
feel like I'm striving for something
other than pressing you and how it works
and I think one of the things that you
you need to remember and like not forget
about is like the first form of endgame
content we know what's called becoming a
cup I returned what not and we know that
those mysterious NPCs we've been told
about one of the NPC's said hey when you
hit you know level five and all your
factions why don't you go and talk to me
again so I hit all my level fives and I
went back to speak to the NPC's again
when I was at level 10 and they were
like oh hey let us know when you're
level 15 and whatnot and so I'm not
really sure like what that max level
that I'm looking for is to get to but I
know that there's something at the end
of the tunnel I know that there's
something that I'm striving towards
whether it's you get voyages from the
pirate Lord and those are a completely
different faction and those are maybe
not fetch quests and they're different
but the promise is that
the amount of time it's going to take to
get to that and gain content that first
piece of endgame camp that is a
significant amount of time yeah there's
this light at the end of this very very
very long tunnel but there's no carrots
like small little surprises waiting for
me along the way I know like alright I
get some money maybe some more involved
quests that have me island hopping a bit
more but still all that is money that I
use for cosmetics which frankly like
I'll probably deck my pirate out but
beyond that I don't really care
yeah really the only two things you can
purchase right now are cosmetic items
and you can purchase titles I'm pretty
short down the road but those just kind
of we're talking about this earlier
changes the perception of how other
people see you like they might see this
big dark looking ship with you know
these these pirates who are decked out
but honestly like you and I on day one
in our you know regular sailor clothing
could easily take down their ship no
matter what right that's the thing right
I don't think that's gonna be a secret
to anybody everyone's going to know like
yeah you look cool but that's also gonna
make you a bigger target if you look
like you're some highfalutin pirate
who's really good anyone who doesn't
have that experience is going to want to
test themselves whether they know it or
not that they can take you down they're
probably gonna try
that's okay like if this game was all we
know naval battles and stuff it'd be
awesome but I actually don't run into
people as often or frequently as I'd
like to
yeah I wonder if part of that too is all
the server issues because I may be yeah
all day Tuesday or almost all day
Tuesday when the game launched could
play we're having issues Monday night
when it like first launched if that
changes if it ramps up that will be
great for me personally yeah I agree I'd
love to see more because I I was playing
with some friends last night and I was
like don't worry guys like the fun part
is when we run into pirates now where
are these other pirates I'm like they're
they'll be there they'll be there we
finally run into some and they just
briefed us the entire time
but it keeps me playing apart from
having to review it obviously is the
idea of playing with you guys it is
having fun I don't really care what her
goals are I don't really care where
we're gonna get out of it all I know is
that we're gonna laugh I'm gonna have
fun you're gonna get drunk and fall off
a boat while puking on whoever is trying
to steer the ship yeah like like those
are those are that's such a small piece
of the game that is one of the most
memorable things that I've done so far
yeah that's not awful that's okay but
like the game has to kind of figure out
like what it wants to focus on and I
know that that's really not it and so I
just I need anymore yeah that's pretty
much how I feel like I I I've played a
decent amount now and I think the base
is really strong like I have a lot of
fun you know managing a crew like
assigning different roles different
people I'm hoping that come a couple
months down the line there will be a lot
more to it there'll be a lot more things
to do and not just different sorts of
fetch quests but like more variety to
what we're doing and that makes me a
little sad because when when it comes
out there I was really hoping that maybe
there were a couple tricks up their
sleeves that maybe there were other
factions that were gonna be introduced I
I think there's definitely room to grow
I just wish it was I wish it was they
are already like I'm dying to see all
these new things because as a player who
played through the alphas and the beta's
and scale test and everything I feel
like to an extent I've played a lot of
these things the only difference is here
everything carries over my faction
reputation carries over my gold carries
over the weapons that I buy carries over
everything seems to carry over I want to
run into the Kraken more often you know
we ran into the crack and only once and
we've played a significant amount of
time we've only been able to do a raid
once I want more emergent gameplay I
want more
Shen's I just I want more time will tell
yeah we shall see uh lunch yeah I'm
ready
were you thinking wait wait wait wait
Jake I owe you yesterday for lunch
here's one doubloon for sandwich and one
for chips and drink thanks man